Hallo Stefan.
Es ist schon neues Jahr, aber wir handeln noch den Salon vom Dezember 21 ab.
Ganz genau, wir wünschen erst mal ein gutes neues Jahr und hoffen, dass Silvester nicht viele Menschen vor dem Fernseher gesessen haben. Ich habe es gemacht. Ich wollte mal schauen, was wird die ARD, was wird das ZDF bringen? Wir sind jetzt im zweiten Jahr Silvester Pandemie. Das heißt, man könnte sich ja mal irgendetwas Neues einfallen lassen. Wieder standen vor dem Brandenburger Tor keine Menschen, sondern nur Moderatoren auf der Bühne und ein paar Sänger. Da war wieder Johannes B. Kerner und Andrea Kiwi Kiewel haben moderiert. Und dann waren aber wieder die Altbekannten dort. Und zwischendurch gab es dann immer mal wieder den Blick in das ein oder andere prominente Wohnzimmer. Da saß dann ein Olli Pocher oder eine Sonja Zietlow. Und die haben ein bisschen erzählt, wie sie jetzt Silvester verbringen oder welche Shows und Bücher sie als nächstes rausbringen. Es war sehr frustrierend. Es trat dort wieder Bonnie Tyler auf. Man muss dazu wissen, Bonnie Tyler tritt im Wechsel-Sivester entweder in der ARD oder im ZDF auf. In der ARD trat dafür Johnny Logan auf. Diese Silvester-Gala wird ja schon im November gedreht, fertig produziert. Und dann wird nur gewartet, bis Silvester ist. Die feiern auch da ins neue Jahr rein, aber dann halt zwei Monate vorher. Da war Johnny Logan, du kennst ihn, oder?
Ich kenne nur Paul Logan.
Nein, nein, nein, Johnny Logan, Compris-Gewinner, zweifacher. Sein großer Titel.
Zweifacher?
Johnny Logan, im weißen Anzug stand er da. Jedenfalls ist er auch, glaube ich, nur noch in Deutschland ein Star. Jedenfalls ist er Silvester immer fest gebucht, war also auch schon häufig zu diesen Shows da. Manchmal auch mit Bonnie Tyler zusammen im Duett. Diesmal haben sie sich aufgeteilt. Einer geht in die ARD, die andere ins ZDF. Und es ist ein Trauerspiel und ich habe einen Bekannten in England, dem habe ich erzählt, ja, bei uns tritt ja Silvester immer euer Star Bonnie Tyler auf. Und dann sagte er, ja, aber wie, die tritt bei euch noch in einer Silvester-Show auf? Was denn da los? Und dann sagt er, ja, wie ist die bei euch nicht mehr? Und dann sagt er, nee, also, ja, irgendwo kommt die mal vor, aber die würde niemals in einer Silvester-Show noch einen Platz bekommen. Hab ich gesagt, Siehste, deswegen kommen wir wahrscheinlich recht günstig dran. Aber es war etwas für dich dabei, Stefan. Ich will dich nicht nur meckern. Es war etwas für dich dabei in der ARD. Du hast ja mal erzählt, eigentlich ist dein Vorbild Udo Jürgens.
Richtig.
Was das Altern angeht und dann auch das Sterben. Also man geht spazieren, fällt um und der Tod ist 80.
Man geht spazieren, hat einen wunderschönen Tag, legt sich abends ins Bett und wacht morgens nicht wieder auf.
Ja, er ist ja beim Spaziergang gestorben. Und noch die neue Tour im Kopf. Also er war gerade schon am Plan, was wird im Januar alles kommen. 80 Jahre, sehr fit und dann aus dem Leben gerissen. Ich würde dir empfehlen, dir bei YouTube mal den Auftritt von Peter Kraus anzusehen. Peter Kraus ist ein Star der 50er Jahre, so der deutsche Rock'n'Roller. Ich konnte damit nie viel anfangen. Aber Peter Kraus ist noch immer auf der Bühne und er ist 82, beherrscht den Hüftschwung wahnsinnig gut, er kann auch richtig gut singen und es ist so faszinierend zu sehen, was dieser 82-Jährige, dem man es wirklich nicht ansieht, dort auf der Bühne vollbringt, dass ich dachte, vielleicht noch mal drüber nachdenken, ob das auch noch ein Modell sein können, kannst du auf jeden Fall noch länger leben. Peter Kraus, sehr fit, rank und schlank. Ich war doch ganz begeistert, dass der 82-Jährige eigentlich auch der einzige war, der ein bisschen Stimmung in die Bude gebracht hat.
Also meine Vorbilder müssen nicht zwingend noch leben. Ich kann auch gut mit Udo Jürgens aus diesem Genre leben. Allerdings, für alle, die sich jetzt fragen, was hat der Wolfgang da nur getan? Also mir kommt Johnny Logan nicht mal bekannt vor, wenn ich in den Bilder suche, weil ich ihm starte. Ich erkenne so ein bisschen, warum er eingeladen wird anhand der Bilder.
Ja, vielleicht, weil er 1954 geboren ist.
Sagt mir gar nichts, ist verrückt. Das mit der Bühne verstehe ich nicht.
Du bist aber auch kein ESC-Zuschauer, oder?
Ich doch. Eigentlich schon.
Aber das sind schon die Klassiker. Also zweimal gewonnen und dann noch irgendein Siegerhit geschrieben.
Aber wahrscheinlich vor meiner Zeit. Ich hab ja...
In den 80ern.
Ja, das ist ja weit vor meiner Zeit. Ich lebe ja, wir reden gleich über Matrix, aber das ist schon fast ein Brückenbau. Ich lebe ja nicht in einer Welt, in der ich ständig Nost- oder Ostalgie brauche, um mich noch vororten zu können. Deswegen brauche ich, um Gefallen am ESC zu finden, nicht die 80er. Wenn dann noch mal die 60er, wann hat Udo Jorgens gewonnen? 66 oder so? Es war ja sehr früh, Marie-Merci-Cherie. Das nehme ich heute noch mal mit. Vor allem, ich habe es hier schon mal gesagt, ich oute mich jetzt vielleicht nicht zum ersten Mal, aber diese Version, die Helene Fischer von Marie-Merci-Cherie für ihn singt, während er in der ersten Reihe Publikum sitzt, weil er Geburtstag feiert und das man im Fernsehen überträgt, ist herzerwärmend, muss ich wirklich sagen. Du hast mir jetzt empfohlen, Peter Krause, ich empfehle dir YouTube, Peter Krause.
Ja, ich kenne natürlich den Auftritt von Helene Fischer, bevorzuge aber dennoch die Uli-Jürgens-Version.
Ja, ich beide, ich bin da ganz unentschieden, aber ich höre beide gerne.
Ich finde, die Stimme ist mir zu glatt von Helene Fischer, aber es stimmt selbstverständlich, es ist nur Nostalgie. Also ARD und ZDF, ich hab mich gefragt, was machen die eigentlich hier? Also es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das das erste Mal sehe, sondern was machen die eigentlich hier? Die Bühne ist das Brandenburger Tor, also im Hintergrund das Brandenburger Tor, alles vorne aufgebaut. Normalerweise sind da tausende Menschen, durfte ja nicht sein wegen Corona. Also ist man vor einer, ja, Lehre tritt man dort auf, es wird ein bisschen Applaus eingespielt. Und im November war es ja noch ein bisschen besser mit Corona. Da hat man dann in dieser Halle auf Abstand gefeiert und da waren dann diese anderen Stars auch die ganze Zeit mit im Publikum. Also man hat ein bisschen Silvester-Flair produziert. Aber ich hab mich natürlich gefragt, was machen diese beiden Sender da? Und eigentlich werden diese Sendungen nur produziert, um den Menschen die Angst vor dem neuen Jahr zu nehmen, um ihnen zu sagen, es wird alles so bleiben, wie es ist. Auch die 70-jährige Bonnie Tyler wird im nächsten Jahr wieder Totally Clips of the Heart singen.
Ja, es werden ja heute Zeitungen gemacht, in denen quasi die Inhalte von damals noch mal und zwar nicht geupdatet werden, sondern noch mal die Erinnerung an die Inhalte von damals.
Das hab ich auch kürzlich gesehen, ich war irritiert.
Das ist total irre. Also für Rentenrepublik ist natürlich alles super. Ich schreibe gerade wahnsinnig gerne an diesem Buch. Und da wir jetzt einmal schon tief drinstecken im Hasenloch, müssen wir noch kurz über Matrix sprechen. Ich hab ihn auch gesehen. Du hast mit jedem Wort in deiner Filmanalyse recht. Es ist kein guter Film. Vor allem für den Anspruch, wir haben ja schon mal mit Matrix vorgelegt und jetzt, na gut, wir hatten noch ein paar Ideen im Köcher. Nee, ihr wolltet einfach nur noch einen Film machen. Es strotzt vor Leere, muss man echt sagen. Es ist nichts drin. Vor allem, wenn man dann doch 25 Stunden Westworld oder so serviert bekommt und denkt, ja komm, dann gehen wir nochmal Matrix gucken. Und man kriegt genau Null. Also gar nichts. Ich bin schwer enttäuscht. Aber ich hab ja eine zweite Gehirnhälfte. Eine, die du nicht hast. Ich kann ja umswitchen. Ich kann ja denken, aber coole Schauspieler. Und die hast du vergessen zu erwähnen in deiner Filmanalyse. Aber das war zu erwarten.
Ich erwähne Schauspieler ja fast nie. Aber selbstverständlich müssen wir den Schauspielern bei solchen Filmen immer besonders dankbar sein. Also sich vorzustellen, wie das wäre, wenn jetzt das Ensemble des Traumschiffs Matrix spielen würde. Matrix 4. Dann würde man, glaube ich, schreiend aus dem Saal rausrennen und das tut man nicht, weil dann in Keanu Reeves trotzdem abliefert.
Und ich finde Keanu Reeves, sag es mal so, er ist ja mittlerweile so eine ganz eigene Form von Pop. Er schmückt sich im Internet, er hat hier mit Cyberpunk und so weiter, überall ist er verortet, hat sich zur Legende gemacht in der Vogue Bewegung, weil er Frauen bei Fototerminen, wenn sie ihn ansprechen, kriege ich ein Selfie mit dir? Niemals sie berührt, sondern die Hand nur hinter sie hält und alle sind beeindruckt von diesem 5 cm Gap, den er da lässt, um niemandem so nahe zu kommen. Selbst wenn die Fans eigentlich zu ihm wollen.
Ob das die Fans so wollen, weiß ich halt nicht.
Ich frage mich dann so, was ist genau die Beobachtung, dass man, dass er reflektiert, dass sie gar nicht mit ihm als Person, sondern mit ihm als Figur das Selfie machen wollen und er deswegen diese Distanz dann ordentlich einschätzt und nicht ausnutzt oder wie auch immer. Also das ist total verrückt. Deswegen würde ich sogar bei dieser Matrix Schauspielerei Keanu Reeves einfach mal rausnehmen, denn wie sein langes Haar sich bewegt, während er den Kopf dreht, kennt man es auch schon aus anderen Filmen. Also selbst das ist da nicht neu. Aber die Rolle des Smith wird ja jetzt von Jonathan Groff oder wie er heißt gespielt, den wir aus gar nicht allzu vielen Rollen kennen. Aber er hat die Königsrolle in Hamilton, spielt also, ist wenig zu sehen, wenn er so alleine auf der Bühne und spielt dort als einzig weiser Schauspieler den britischen König in einer sagenhaften Performance. Also wirklich ganz, ganz großartig. Und vielleicht kennst du es, die Serie Mindhunter. Und die ist ja nun, also gerade die erste Staffel, ein wirkliches Spektakel, wie sie beide losziehen, also er als junger mit so einem Senior FBI Typ und das Prinzip Serienmord entwickeln, also für das FBI, das einfach diese akademische Arbeit machen und dann diese Gespräche dafür in den Gefängnissen. Also sie gehen zu den schon verurteilten Mördern und wollen herausfinden, was macht sie zu Serienmördern? Und das ist die einzige Serie, von der ich sagen kann, hört sie euch wirklich mit Kopfhörern an, weil das so erstklassig mikrofoniert und also diese Dialoge sind einfach so erstklassig produziert, dass man es wirklich machen muss. Und ich finde, es war genau der richtige Cast für diese Smith-Rolle, gerade in dieser Doppelzüngigkeit, die dazt drinsteckt. Der erste Smith, 99, war ja einer, der ist ja frontal, der wollte ja richtig Morpheus sagen, hier, ich gehöre eigentlich gar nicht dazu, ich drückte jetzt meine Lebenslogik oder meine, sozusagen, Lebens, kann man gar nicht sagen, meine Art von künstlicher Intelligenz, die dir menschlichen Viruscharakter so überlegen ist, die drück ich dir jetzt mal richtig aufs Auge. Und das ist ja so ein bisschen abgegradet, er spielt ja den Chef sozusagen und gibt sich gar nicht zu erkennen, also er will gar nicht so dieser, ich bin das, HD. Smith und so, sondern er hält sich da zurück und das wird wirklich sehr gut gespielt von dem Typ. Also ich hab den auch im Original gesehen und die Stimme und so, das Aussehen, auch diese, das machen sie ja wirklich sehr gut, dass sie diese Kämpfe immer mal unterbrechen mit so kleinen Dialogen, weil man weiß, na die Kämpfe sind eh irgendwie sinnlos, weil die kämpfen ja nur so über drei Ecken, das ist ja nicht wirklich eine körperliche Auseinandersetzung und so. Und dann diese Dialoge dazwischen und mit diesem Jonathan Croft, ist das wirklich eine Freude zu sehen, wär nur schön, wenn noch jemand mit Intelligenz am Drehbuch mitgeschrieben hätte.
Tatsächlich, und man wundert sich so, denn es liegt ja doch noch viel auf der Hand, was man eigentlich machen könnte. Wir sprechen ja heute über Peter Thiel, davon lassen sich ja einige gute Drehbücher ableiten und da führt vieles direkt in die Matrix und wieder raus und an der roten Pille vorbei. All das werden wir ja thematisieren müssen. Aber man wundert sich, dass da so wenig von im Drehbuch da ist, dass man erstmal ein bisschen so die Produktionsbedingungen reflektiert, unter denen der Film entsteht. Das macht man in Form dieses Videospiels, das dort eine Fortsetzung erfahren soll. Und dann sagt man eigentlich ja damit, naja, die Firma will, um Umsatz zu machen, halt einfach noch einen Teil produzieren und wahrscheinlich ist damit auch ausgesagt oder sagt Leiner Wachowski, sie hätten es auch ohne mich gemacht. Sie wollten halt einen neuen Teil Matrix haben. Und das wird jetzt alles so ein bisschen dort auf die Schippe genommen oder zum Teil auch dann vielleicht immanent kritisiert. Aber das ist ja nichts, was uns eigentlich dann weiterführt, sondern wir erwarten ja eigentlich dann schon nochmal von einem neuen Matrix eine Antwort auf Fragen oder beziehungsweise müsste er neue Fragen aufwerfen. Also Fragen, die wir uns jetzt, glaube ich, gleich in Bezug auf Peter Thiel und die Zukunft der Digitalisierung Web3 und so weiter stellen müssen. Diese Fragen werden aber gar nicht aufgegriffen. Also das Kino ist hier dann auch so irrelevant plötzlich, was mich so ärgert. Und dass es dann auch im Kino stattfindet, ist einfach nur dem geschuldet, dass man sagt, ja wir wollen halt noch einen Film machen und es funktioniert auch noch einmal. Natürlich gehen die Leute auch dann sich nochmal Matrix 4 ansehen, aber der fünfte würde dann wirklich vermutlich nicht mehr funktionieren, vielleicht in 15 Jahren dann wieder. Aber das ist einfach sehr, sehr ärgerlich und wir können eh sehen, dass das Kino ja eine schlechte Zeit hat. Zwar gibt es die Streaming-Anbieter, aber es ist doch so, dass man mit solchen Produktionen eigentlich keine neue Lust auf das Kino macht. Und alles kann dann Netflix auch nicht rausreißen, denn man muss ja da die Perlen suchen gehen. Du hattest ja, das fand ich ja sehr erstaunlich, beim Fernsehpodcast schon einen Ausschnitt gebracht, weil du dir ja immer diese Kulturzeit-Sendungen und so antust. Da war ja schon Jane Campion's The Power of the Dog vorgestellt. Aber auch interessant, wie, also das will ich auch gleich noch mal thematisieren bezug auf den Theatertext, ein Text über das Theater, dass das immer so gleich auf den Nenner gebracht wird. Dies ist ein Film über die, da, da, da, da, so kommen ja immer diese, diese aus Moderation aus dem Off. Und damit schmälert man selbstverständlich auch immer auf furchtbare Weise die Kunst. Naja, aber Matrix ist eine Enttäuschung, deswegen nochmal hier der Hinweis. Und ich hoffe, ich kann mich auf dich verlassen. Die Kinos haben auf auch in der nächsten Woche. Scream Teil fünf, das könnte was sein. Ja, also die ersten vier Teile sind schon richtig gut. Und da ist diese Matrix-Thematik im Genre des Horrorfilms und Simulation, Baudrillard, alles ist da drin. Nur, ich finde ein bisschen cleverer als jetzt in Teil zwei, drei und vier von Matrix. Und deswegen, der fünfte Teil könnte eine kleine Offenbarung sein. Ich weiß es nicht, ich hoffe es sehr.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt. Du hast es ja schon entsprechend geteasert, könnte da bessere Matrix sein. Ich werde mir jetzt Scream eins. Ich kann mich daran erinnern, die früher gesehen zu haben. Und ich fand ihn nicht schlecht. Er hat, glaube ich, aber das weiß ich noch ganz dunkel gute Pointen. Und jetzt bin ich natürlich so angefixt, dass ich denke, nein, ich warte nicht bis März, um mir Batman anzugucken, sondern dann gucke ich mir vielleicht auch Scream 5 im Kino an. Letztes Wort zu Matrix. Ich glaube, die haben einfach all die guten Ideen, die damals in der Diskussion über den ersten Matrix-Film entstanden, jetzt wieder reingebaut. Diese ganzen Gimmicks. Wer ist der Architekt? Komm, wir machen einfach mal Neo selber zum Architekten. Es ist nur ein Videospiel und so. Er hat dann diese ganzen Ideen. Kann man aus der Matrix raus, rein raus werden? Die Software auch? Ja, komm, die Software können wir auch hin und her und so weiter. Extracten. Und ich hätte den Film einfach Matrix Review genannt, statt irgendwelche anderen Sachen. Das hätte dann auch Reload, Revolution.
Stimmt.
Und dann 20 Jahre später nochmal Review und dann ist gut. Stattdessen so eine alberne Spielerei, die nicht funktioniert. Gut, man kann auch scheitern. Es sind Kunstwerke und in deren Sicht mein Urteil. Es ist leider gescheitert, schmellert nichts an Matrix 1. Also den haben wir jetzt nochmal mit großer Freude hier gesehen.
Auf keinen Fall. Und ich würde sagen, wer sich ein bisschen für diese ganzen Thematiken interessiert, kann ihn sich trotzdem ansehen. Es ist ja auch immer Kind seiner Zeit, vielleicht auch ein Ausdruck der großen Ratlosigkeit, die wir sehen. Vielleicht ist dieser Film nicht viel anders als die Politik, die das Digitale nicht entsprechend regulieren kann, weil sie es nicht versteht. Auch so kann man diesen Film natürlich sehen. Deswegen bin ich da immer ganz froh, wenn ich das auch gesehen habe. Ich hätte mir natürlich einen besseren Film gewünscht, aber ich kann sagen, man verdrödelt viel Zeit sonst auf Streamingplattformen oder so mit sehr viel Mist oder man wird dann so zugemüllt mit irgendwas, was einmal gut ist. Und dann jetzt bei Tiger King war die erste Staffel in gewisser Weise interessant, aber dann macht man noch mal eine zweite und kann sich nur die Haare raufen und sagen, wie kann das sein, dass man überhaupt noch mal so einen Stuss dann da fortsetzen will. Insofern glaube ich, ist eine Auseinandersetzung auch dann mit einem solchen nicht gelungenen, gescheiterten Produkt durchaus erhellend und erkenntnisfördernd. Nicht so erkenntnisfördernd, aber wie die Biografie, die wir gelesen haben, begeistert. Also das ist wirklich ein großer Wurf, eine Biografie über Peter Thiel. Und wir sind so begeistert, weil diese Biografie natürlich alles andere als eine Heldengeschichte uns erzählt, sondern wirklich eine kritische Biografie ist. Und nicht nur eine, die sich aufspießt an Personen und was sie genau tat, sondern die es einzuordnen weiß. Ich würde sagen, wir haben ja das Buch von Adrian Daub gelesen über das Silicon Valley. Und hier nun sehen wir eigentlich den Film dazu, beziehungsweise auch noch eine tiefergehende Analyse. Jetzt geht's in die Einzelheiten. Es kommen die alten Protagonisten von Carl Schmidt bis ein Rent wieder vor, René Girard. Aber wir sehen auch hier ein Weltbild, das sich möglicherweise durchsetzen könnte in den USA und auch in anderen Teilen der Welt, was einen wirklich beängstigt. Also es ist ein Buch, das glaube ich auch ganz viel noch mal über das Trump-Zeitalter uns erzählt. Und zwar auf völlig andere Weise, als wir das jetzt aus den Biografien gelernt haben. Ich bin sehr, sehr begeistert.
Genau, wir gehen gleich ausführlich drauf ein. Für alle, die nicht Salonmitglieder sind oder Salonmitglieder und uns dann immer, obwohl sie unsere Besprechungen schon, was weiß ich, eine Stunde über, no filter, Instagram, wie auch immer, diese ganzen Facebook-Bücher, was alles gibt, wir haben ja vieles besprochen, dann kriegen wir immer mal wieder Hinweise, Fotos bei Twitter oder Instagram oder wie auch immer. Menschen haben, weil sie uns gehört haben, dann diese Bücher gekauft. Und sehr häufig frage ich mich dann, wieso? Wir haben doch eigentlich gesagt, so toll ist es nicht. Aber diesmal, wenn man sich jetzt wirklich fragt, 2022, welches Buch über das Silicon Valley, über die Silicon Valley Protagonisten, muss ich jetzt wirklich lesen, wo erfahre ich was über das Silicon Valley und die Welt, in der Silicon Valley regiert, dann ist das das Buch. Also dann muss man dieses Peter Thiel, wie der Pate des Silicon Valley die Welt beherrscht, von Max Chevkin lesen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen nur in diesem FPV-Stadt, sozusagen, so ein bisschen prominenter platziert auf Deutsch. Das ist ein bisschen komisch, könnte abschrecken, muss aber nicht.
Ja, man hätte gedacht, das ist auch ein Buch, das bei C. H. Beck jetzt erscheinen könnte. Zum Beispiel wäre er ein ganz klassischer Biografie-Verlag. Aber ja, ist ein bisschen eigenartig, dass sie sich das schnell gekrallt haben oder sie waren einfach sehr, sehr schnell. Man weiß es nicht. Jedenfalls können wir sehr froh sein, dass es jetzt übersetzt vorliegt oder fast zeitgleich erschien.
Genau, also in der Ansicht gleich unsere Besprechung. Und greift dann zu diesem Buch, auch wenn ihr was verschenken wollt oder so. Das kann man gut verschenken und sich dann von denen, denen man es geschenkt hat, gut erzählen lassen und dann selber lesen irgendwann.
Und die Politiker sollten es auch lesen.
Ganz wichtig, wenn ihr jemanden in Berlin kennt, schenkt sie dieses Buch an die neue junge SPD-Bundestag-Fraktion, die sich gerade aufmacht, die Welt zu verändern. Vielleicht auch mal bei Peter Thiel nachlesen oder bei Jeffkin über Thiel.
Zum Beispiel, was hast du noch anzubieten?
Ich habe einen Doppelschlag der New York Times zur Einflussnahme Chinas in die Welt via Silicon Valley. Am Anfang war es so, China wissen wir, Great Firewall und so weiter. Sie schützen ihr Land, schotten es ab. Keine ausländischen Dienste sind dort zugegen. Sie kontrollieren diesen abgeschotteten Teil der Welt. Neuerdings, und die New York Times sieht hier eine Wendung und macht das auch ein bisschen investigativ, greift doch die chinesische Regierung ins allgemeine Internet aus und zielt auch auf die Chinesen im Ausland, die natürlich immer noch Familie zu Hause haben. Was für die chinesische Regierung so eine Art, da können wir doch darüber Druck aufbauen. Außerdem Influencer, die aus China gesteuert werden, mit ganz erstaunlichen Zahlen, also es geht wirklich gruselig zur Sache. Dann bleibe ich kurz in der Weltregion. Japan hat nun eingesehen und es ist ein sehr knapper Text, der ein ganz, ganz großes Problem, das uns auch noch ereilen wird, kurz beschreibt. Habe ich gar nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt, sondern ein Leser hat mich darauf hingewiesen. In einem ganz knappen Text im Freitag wird kurz dargestellt, wie sich Japan einsehend, dass weder die Maschinen noch die Ausländer, die Alten pflegen, was man eigentlich macht. Und es ist eine ganz große Verzweiflung, die noch versucht wird, in politische Programme zu gießen. Außerdem haben die Krautreporter 66 gute Nachrichten aus 2021 aufgegriffen. Wir gehen davon mal zehn durch und fragen uns, also wenn das die guten Nachrichten sind, dann sieht es schlecht aus. Und dann noch ein ganz kleiner Text zu Apple mit einer ganz interessanten Kalkulation. Was wäre eigentlich, wenn man sich 2008, als das iPhone auf den Markt kam, kein iPhone, sondern für den Geld Apple-Aktien gekauft hätte? Kann man schon mal im Kopf mitrechnen. Wie viel Geld hätte ich dann heute?
Genau, das ist der Unterschied zwischen investieren und konsumieren. Da kann man noch mal diese ganz alte Hans-Werner-Sinnlogik sogar auffahren, sagen, also Konsum sparen, ja, also Konsum verzicht und dann Vermögensaufbau. Also da bei Apple wird es vermutlich sogar gehen, was da immer ausgeheckt wird. Ich habe ein Buch über Indien gelesen mit Essays von Arundhati Roy. Asadi heißt Freiheit. In Indien geht es schlimm zu und schon lange und es wird schlimmer. Und auch hier sehen wir, wie eine neue Form von Nationalismus sich dort ausbreitet, eine ungeheure Muslimenfeindlichkeit. Es ist sehr beängstigend, was man da lesen kann. Nicht alles neu, aber doch noch mal in dieser Form erschreckend. Dann, das letzte Mal angekündigt jetzt, aber realisiert. Ich spreche über einen sehr, sehr umfangreichen Gedichtband von Pier Paolo Pasolini, der jetzt bei Surkamp herausgegeben wurde, mit sehr schön, sehr politischen, sehr intimen Gedichten. Außerdem blicken wir nach Dänemark. Die überlegen, dass sie doch vielleicht die, die sie abschieben wollen und die ins Gefängnis müssen, die in irgendeiner Weise straffällig geworden sind, man die nicht auch outsourcen kann und da im Kosovo einfach mal Gefängnisse anmietet. Ein wirklich ganz erschreckender Text. Man muss nur mit dem Kopf schütteln. Wir sprechen ganz kurz über die Off-Szene im Theater. Was läuft da eigentlich schief? Da gibt es eine Kolumne zu. Und einen langen Text, den ich aber doch ausführlich vorstellen möchte, aus Foreign Affairs von Paracana, den wir ja schon kennen. Wir haben über sein Buch Move gesprochen. Und er findet Metaverse und all das, was da kommt, ganz großartig. Es sind absurde Thesen, die er da vorstellt, aber es ist vielleicht doch ganz gut, sich damit zu beschäftigen, gerade mit diesem Teal-Gespenst im Rücken.
Wir haben uns ja gewundert, als wir Move gelesen haben, über das Ende. Warum hat er da so komische...
Und da geht's jetzt weiter.
Okay, sehr gut. Ja, das klingt sehr gut. Gut, dann gehen wir jetzt in den Salon. Begrüßen euch dort alle ein zweites Mal. Und für alle, die nicht Salon-Mitglieder sind, wir hören uns dann Ende des Monats. Bis dann.
Bis dann.